BACK AT THIS.
>> John G.: I AM SO EXCITED.
AND NK THAT THAT
HAD JUST TICKED
HIGH-STICK BY MILLER, BUT P ALEI
NOW TO KEVIN FIALA, A DROP THE R
NASHVILLE PREDATOR, IN
ONTO THE ICE.
>> John G.: I WONDER IF SEASON.
AND ON THIS LINE NOW WITH
TO
SPRING GARLAND ON THIS ONE.
THAT THE PENALTY.
FIALA, LEFT WING. DUMBA AND FOL,
BOTH OF THEM WEARING "
BREAKAWAY, SCORES!
MATS
ERIKSSON EK, TAPE-TO-TAPE.
>> John G.: YES, TAPE-TO-TAPE
AND ZU GREENWAY, SPECTACULAR
AS THAT ONEKABLE STOP ON THAT
ONE-TIMER BY BROCK
GARLAND WITH IT.
BOESER. INVOLVED
THAT ONE AND ZUCCARELLO KAPRIZOT
BACK THE OTHERLOCKED,
REBOUND AND HE BACKHANDS IT IN.D
RIGHT THERE,
PRESSURE FROM GREENWAY AND THAT
PASS NOWN
IN FRONT AND THEY SCORE!
CHAISSON!
ELIAS PETTERSSON PASS, ALL
CHAISSON HAD TO DO THROUGH.
I WAS THINKING OFR THAT PUCK IN
ON EKMAN-LARSSON, CUTTINGBACKHAT
AND OFF OF THE POST SHOW AND
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN HIS FIRSTN.
AND A LEAD PASS, PITLICKNIGHT OD
TALBOT, NOT AS ACROBATICOAL.
AND DUHAIME THE OTHER WAY
AND PITLICK, CENTRES WAY.
THE CANUCKS COVERAGE, MATT DUMB
YEAH HERE SLIERE,
TRAILING THINGS AND DO
YOUR REGULAR ROUTI HERE
WITH HORVAT, BUSTING IN, TO RIGO
BO HORVAT AND HERE, YOU CANT, DS
IT.
IT IS DEMKO WHO SPINS AROUND,